[Music]
u.s intelligence reports russia has 80
percent of its forces ready to launch a
full-scale invasion of ukraine
more than 100 000 russian troops are
amassed along ukraine's border and the
rest are on route missiles and other
military equipment are in place too
we're in the window when a russian
invasion can start at any time if
president putin so decides
that includes in the coming days u.s
president joe biden held a high-stakes
call with russian president vladimir
putin saturday urging him to stand down
the u.s embassy is being evacuated only
core diplomatic staff will remain
american citizens are being told to
leave the country too biden is warning
putin not to harm any americans i'm
hoping
that if in fact he's foolish enough to
go in he's smart enough not to in fact
do anything that would negatively impact
on american citizens
u.s soldiers helping to train ukraine's
army have also reportedly left the
country but an additional 3 000 american
troops are heading to poland joining two
thousand others already deployed to
eastern europe these are not soldiers
who are being sent to go fight russia in
ukraine they're going to defend
nato territory putin is trying to stop
ukraine from joining nato giving an
international military protection the
canadian government is also urging its
citizens to leave ukraine the
ukrainian-canadian congress which
represents roughly 1.4 million canadians
of ukrainian heritage wants the trudeau
government to punish russia immediately
we think that it's time to do some
sanctions today tomorrow the next week
so that putin understands that we're
serious about this and he can face some
consequences if there is an invasion the
u.s and his allies are promising
punishing economic sanctions against
putin and his billionaire backers
blocking financial transactions around
the world for now putin denies he plans
an attack which experts say would have
devastating effects there would be a
very bad humanitarian crisis and loss of
life
several world leaders have offered to
negotiate a diplomatic solution to the
situation but putin has rebuffed those
attempts now a tense world watches and
waits for what could be the greatest
security crisis between russia and the
west since the cold war
jennifer johnson global news washington